Sandra Oh is proud to be making history
I'm ecstatic about it the killing Eve
star is the first Asian woman to earn an
Emmy nomination in the Lead Actress
category for her role as mi5 agent Opel
Astra she will keep hurting people until
I catch her I have to find her
she wants me to find her how does that
make you feel and and do you open your
arms right up to you know to carry that
on your shoulders yes you have it
absolutely correctly I open my arms wide
open to carry that for anyone who you
know wants to come on the ride with me
I'm ecstatic about it and I do have
complete awareness of what this
particular might mean for our community
and and I'm happy to represent I've
talked to some other ladies in your
category and I feel like your cat first
of all it oh come on
no no then I think you know what that is
exactly what it's supposed to be it's an
illusionary you all are just the
broadest fantastic broad you know it's
just so great yeah I mean it's amazing
to want to be able to meet everyone to
be able to congratulate each other you
know for everyone's work I'm just so
pleased to be in this category with this
weaker woman I've noticed a real
outpouring of love for you to do from
your Grey's Anatomy family what did that
mean for you oh it's well you know they
know me and they really know me and I
know everyone is happy for me and I
really really appreciate their support
[Music]
you